[Music]
the Spider-Man universe of Sony
continues to grow steadily and the next
project is already planned for early
2024. the talk is of Madame Webb if you
know the comics you may already be
familiar with her but for those who have
only watched the Spider-Man movies this
is a brand new character brought to life
on the big screen what Madame web is all
about and what is known about the movie
so far is revealed to you in this video
so stay tuned
since the comic book character named
Cassandra Webb might be new to most of
you let's have a more in-depth look at
her backstory she was born blind in
Salem Oregon and has suffered from
Myasthenia an autoimmune disease since
birth this weakened her physically but
led to the development of special mental
talents in addition to her psychic
abilities she can communicate
telepathically she can sense upcoming
dangers in advance and similar to Doctor
Strange leave her body through astral
projection this is particularly useful
because she is severely impaired due to
her illness and is confined most of the
time to a special chair that looks like
the center of a spider's web by the way
the Civil name of the comic character is
no coincidence Cassandra is a well-known
mythological figure of antiquity and the
daughter of the Trojan King preamp she
was cursed by the god Apollo to be able
to see into the future but never to be
believed despite her warnings she is
therefore considered a tragic heroine
she sees the threat but cannot avert it
her equivalent Cassandra Webb is
hopefully faded for a different destiny
the character first made its appearance
in the 1980 comic The Amazing Spider-Man
number 210 there Spider-Man seeks out
Cassandra to help him locate a kidnap
victim at first Spidey doesn't have
faith in her powers however when she
suddenly shows up at his apartment and
reveals to him that she knows his
identity they become allies in later
Adventures she frequently helps him
foresee crimes Madame Webb also made an
appearance in the 1994 animated series
naturally the big question is who will
play the title role of Madam Webb
besides the casting of the mystical
Clairvoyant quite a lot is already known
about the cast this much in advance we
will see many well-known female faces
from Hollywood
Madame Webb will be played by Dakota
Johnson who most of you are likely to
recognize from her starring role in 50
Shades of Gray but fans of sophisticated
horror might also know her from the
remake of Suspiria in the case of Madam
Webb she outshone other actresses like
Charlize Theron or Amy Adams who were
also considered many comic fans are
dissatisfied as they consider Johnson
too young for the role however the
decision to cast a relatively young
character is also an indication that
those in charge are looking for a more
long-term portrayal in other movies as
well for Johnson it's her first role in
a comic book adaptation
whether we will see Spider-Man is still
unclear but Spider Woman will play a
major role in Madame Webb Sydney Sweeney
known primarily from the series Euphoria
has been cast for the role even if it
has not been officially confirmed yet it
is considered pretty certain that she
will play Julia Carpenter Julie received
her superpowers in an experiment
involving a mixture of spider venom and
a plant poison the character's
appearance is considered likely in part
because the Crave in the hunter movie
will hit theaters prior to Madame Webb
on October 6 2023. in the comics Julia
plays a crucial role in preventing
Spider-Man from killing Craven but she
may not Remain the only Spider Woman
besides her Celeste O'Connor as Maddie
Franklin and isabelimer said as Anya
corzone have also been cast we were able
to see O'Connor back in 2021's
Ghostbusters afterlife her character
Maddie also has a direct connection to
Madame Webb in the comics in the
Gathering of five ritual people
attempted to use Ancient relics to
transfer special powers to humans while
Madame Webb became Immortal in the
process Maddie acquired superhuman
abilities as well Isabella Merced had
her first big role in Transformers the
last night where she played the young
Isabella her new role Anya Corazon is
the youngest superheroine and is also
called Spider-Girl in the comics she got
her powers from the spider Society they
considered her worthy because she stood
up for the weaker ones in high school
and protected them from school bullies
the rules of O'Connor and Merced have
not been officially confirmed yet but
based on Insider reports they are
regarded as certain rumor has it that a
spider girl movie is also in development
in which case an appearance of the
character in Madame Webb would make
perfect sense
regardless of whether Spider-Man himself
turns up his family definitely plays a
role in Madame Webb both Peter Parker's
mother Mary and his Uncle Ben have been
cast Mary's role will be played by Emma
Roberts while Ben will be played by Adam
Scott Ben in particular is expected to
play a key role in the movie whether we
will also see Aunt May and Spider-Man's
Father Richard Parker remains unknown
the cast is rounded out by actors such
as Zasha Mamet Resident Evil actor Mike
Epps and tahar Rahim nothing is known
about the role so far but there are
rumors that tahar Rahim could play
Ezekiel Sims another version of
Spider-Man
the director of Madam Webb is SJ
Clarkson for her it's the first big
Hollywood project after gaining
experience in the Marvel series The
Defenders we are excited to find out
whether she'll be able to leave an
impression on Sony's spider-verse the
script was written by the same authors
as morbius which will surely cause some
fans to raise a few eyebrows meanwhile
Spider-Man no way home experienced
cinematographer Moro Fiore was
responsible for the camera in charge of
the production is none other than the
producer of the Transformers franchise
Lorenzo di bonaventura he has already
stated that the movie will not primarily
focus on action instead the movie will
be more of a thriller in keeping with
the tricky abilities of the main
character filming began in July 2022 and
was concluded at the end of the year
meaning that the movie is currently in
post-production the film was originally
supposed to be released on July 7 2023
but like so many other projects the
release date got postponed Madame Webb
will now be out in theaters on February
16 2024 so we will likely get to see
some first footage soon with the release
of Craven the hunter in October the
latest there will most certainly be some
updates or a first teaser trailer
those responsible are still remaining
silent about the plot of Madam Webb this
is because the majority of the audience
does not yet know the character and
could therefore be taken by surprise by
the film in an interview with
comicbook.com however the producer
explained that an origin story will be
told and that the mysterious past of the
character from the comics will be
addressed in the interview Spider-Man
fans are said to love the character
because they would learn how she became
the person known from the comics
meanwhile leaked photos from the set
have raised questions about which
versions of Madame Webb and Spider Woman
we will actually see in the final film
we won't go into details here to avoid
spoilers but this much can be said the
movie might have a few surprises in
store even for those who are familiar
with the comics in addition there will
probably be an explanation as to why the
role of the actually very old Cassandra
Webb was cast with an actress in her 30s
a strong hint for speculations about the
story is also the allegedly important
role of Ben Parker most of us actually
know him as the caregiver for his nephew
Peter and he passes away relatively soon
after the start of Peter's superhero
career so it's reasonable to wonder why
he's significant from Adam Webb and when
exactly the movie is supposed to take
place chronologically here we should
consider the title character's ability
to see into the future along with the
young cast that includes Dakota Johnson
thus a plot that is set sometime before
Spider-Man is quite imaginable if not
even before Peter's birth appropriately
the movie was shot in the financial
district of Boston which is supposed to
be representative of 2000's New York
City the first trailer from Adam Webb
will probably bring more clarity we are
looking forward to sharing it with you
on our Channel
right now that's all the current
information about Madame Webb were you
familiar with the character beforehand
and do you feel that Sony's spider-verse
is heading in the right direction can
you think of any spider-verse characters
you'd like to see in a separate movie
please share your thoughts in the
comments and leave a thumbs up if you
liked our little preview thanks for
watching
[Music]
thank you